N
TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST, I AM TIRED OF THE
GOVERNMENT TREATING US LIKE
INFANTS.
INFANTS THAT RELY ON MOMMY AND
DADDY FOR EVERYTHING.
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE THEIR DIAPERS
AND FEED THEM.
INFANTS DON'T DO ANYTHING FOR
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY CAN'T.
IF YOU LEAVE AN INFANT THEY
WON'T SURVIVE.
I GOT TO THINKING, GOVERNMENT
TREATS US LIKE LITTLE CHILDREN
ALL THE TIME.
IT'S NOT JUST AN ACT OF
MISFEASANCE, IT'S AN ACT OF
MALFEASANCE.
GOVERNMENT IS ACTIVELY SCREWING
UP YOUR LIFE.
MISFEASANCE IS IF SOMEONE FALLS
IN FRONT OF YOU ON THE SIDEWALK
AND YOU DON'T HELP THEM UP.
MALFEASANCE IS WHEN THEY TRY TO
GET UP, YOU PUNCH THEM IN THE
FACE.
WHEN YOU DON'T MAKE THE
DECISIONS FOR YOURSELF, THAT
MALFEASANCE BECAUSE THEY STOLE
FROM YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
YOU'RE OWN DECISIONS, TOO CHOOSE
WHERE YOUR CHILDREN GO TO
SCHOOL.
THEY HAVE STOLEN FROM YOU.
A QUICK STORY.
SOMEONE CLOSE TO ME CALLED ME
THIS WEEK.
THEY WERE CRYING, AND IT
BOTHERED ME AND DUG AT ME.
I SO DESPERATELY WANTED TO FIX
HER PROBLEM.
BUT I WOULD HAVE ONLY BEEN
FIXING THE PROBLEM FOR ME, NOT
FOR HER.
IF I DID I WOULD HAVE STOLEN
FROM HER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FIGURE IT OUT.
THAT'S WHAT GOVERNMENT IS
STEALING FROM YOU BY TREATING
EVERYONE OF YOU LIKE INSTANT AND
CHILDREN.
THEY WANT TO MAKE EVERY DECISION
FROM CRADLE TO GRAVE.
REMEMBER THE DECISION WE MADE
ABOUT THE LIFE OF JULIA.
THERE IS SOME GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTION TO MAKE DECISIONS
FOR THEM?
>> REMEMBER PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA'S EMBARRASSING P.R.
CAMPAIGN CALL THE LIFE OF JULIA.
IT TOLD THE STORY OF A WOMAN
DEVOTED HER LIFE AS A DEMOCRAT
FROM START TO FINISH.
IT WAS ALL PROPAGANDA.
INFANTS NEED PARENTS TO SURVIVE.
FREE CITIZENS DON'T NEED
GOVERNMENT TO SURVIVE.
GOVERNMENT CREATES CENTRALIZED
POWER AND IN EXCHANGE SOME
PEOPLE WHO DON'T NEED IT CLAIM
TO WANT IT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY OVER
THEIR WHOLE LIVES.
IF PEOPLE BELIEVE THEY CAN
GOVERN THEMSELVES, GOVERNMENT
HAS A MAJOR PROBLEM.
BIG GOVERNMENT AND THE
POLITICIANS WHO RUN IT TREAT
CITIZENS LIKE INFANTS RELYING ON
BIG DAD QUESTION AND BIG MOMMY
GOVERNMENT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ACTS
LIKE WE ARE LITTLE CHILDREN WHO
CAN'T THINK FOR THEMSELVES.
THE DEFINITION OF INFANTILISM.
IT'S LIKE THEY THINK WE ARE TOO
DUMB AND IMMATURE TO FIGURE OUT
FOR OURSELVES.
WE ARE JUST SUPPOSED TO ACCEPT
THEIR BLATANT LIES AS TRUTH AS
WELL.
LIKE THIS GEM.
>> DO YOU REALIZE THE BULLET OUT
OF AN AR-15 TRAVELS FIVE TIMES
AS RAPIDLY AS A BULLET SHOT OUT
OF ANY OTHER GUN.
>> THEY TALK TO YOU LIKE YOU ARE
CHILDREN.
WE ARE NOT INFANTS, FOLKS.
FAIRYTALES DON'T WORK ON US
UNLESS YOU ARE LIBERAL.
REMEMBER THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT, OBAMACARE?
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE ANSWER
TO GETTING UNINSURED AMERICANS
COVERED AND BRING DOWN
HEALTHCARE COSTS.
NOW AFTER KEEPING MILLIONS ON
THE MEDICARE AND MEDICAID ROLLS.
THE PROBLEMS HAVE GOTTEN WORSE.
AFTER OBAMACARE KICKED MILLIONS
OFF THEIR PLANS.
THIS GUY, TOO, AND AFTER A
WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC THERE ARE
MILLIONS MORE DEPENDENT ON BIG
GOVERNMENT HEALTHCARE.
EVEN WORSE, HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE
ONLY GOING UP.
I THOUGHT THE GOVERNMENT WAS
FIXING THAT.
THEY THINK WE ARE INFANTS AND
FORCE US TO BE COMPLETELY
RELIANT.
THE STUDENT LOAN DEBACLE.
HIGHER EDUCATION HAS ONLY GOTTEN
MORE EXPENSIVE SINCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION GOT
INVOLVED AND STARTED GIVING OUT
PELL GRANTS IN 1972.
NOW IT CAN COST TRILLIONS TOO
PAY OFF THESE STUDENT LOANS.
WE DON'T NEED BIG GOVERNMENT TO
MAKE DECISIONS FOR US.
DURING THE PAN DEMIC PARENTS
PULL THEIR KIDS FROM PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN DROVE.
THEY STARTED VOTING FOR SCHOOL
CHOICE AND VOUCHER SYSTEMS SO
PARENTS COULD TAKE BACK CONTROL.
HOW DID THE GOONS AT THE DOJ
LABEL THESE PARENTS?
AS DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
YOU MAY SAY, YOU ARE
OVERREACTING.
THIS IS AMERICA.
WE ARE FREE TO DO AS WE WANT.
YOU WOULD BE WRONG ABOUT THAT.
HOW ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT STOOGE
IN CALIFORNIA.
GAVIN NEWSOM.
HE THINKS HE SHOULD CHOOSE WHAT
KIND OF CAR YOU BUY.
AND A DOZEN OTHER STATES AGREE
WITH HIM.
SELF STATES WILL FOLLOW
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD IN BANNING GAS
POWERED CAR SALES BY 2035.
YOU WANT TO BUY AN ELECTRIC
POWERED TRUCK, BIDEN'S INFLATION
BILL GAVE $7,500 TAX CREDITS AND
GM RAISED THEIR PRICES BY THE
SAME AMOUNT.
HOW IS IT WORKING OUT FOR YOU?
NOT GREAT, AMERICA.
NOT ONLY DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
TREAT US LIKE CHILDREN.
>> IF PEOPLE WALK INTO TEXAS
UNVACCINATED THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
STAY.
>> THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
IT'S NOT THAT SIMPLE IT NOT JUST
THAT PEOPLE ARE WALKING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
DAN: HERE IS VIDEO.
THAT IS HOW IT WORKS?
YOU CAN SEE WITH YOUR OWN EYES.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WALKING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
THEY THINK WE BELIEVE IN
FAIRYTALES LIKE INFANTS.
THEIR OPEN BORDER POLICY LIKE
EVERYTHING ELSE BIG GOVERNMENT
TOUCHES ONLY MAKES THE CRISIS
WORSE.
I SPEAK FOR MYSELF AND I THINK
TENS OF MILLIONS OTHER
CONSERVATIVE ADULTS WHEN I SAY
THIS TO BIG GOVERNMENT, PLEASE
STOP HELPI